- Hello everyone.
Thank you for joining.
It's a pleasure to be here.
So my name is Lavi, one of
the co-founders of Upwind.
I'm gonna walk you through
our story, what we do,
why the hell do you need to hear
about another cloud security platform,
and what we're doing differently.
So let's kick it off.
So Upwind, we are on a mission
to build the best cloud security platform.
A little bit about us.
We're a team that goes
together for so many years.
We all met together back at the days
in the Israeli military,
coming from a DevOps
infrastructure background.
Upwind is actually the second
company we're building.
The first one was called Spot.
We're building a cloud security...
Sorry, we were building a
cloud automation platform
that was matching the right infrastructure
to the right application,
to the application demand
in terms of performance,
cost, availability.
We were acquired by NetApp in 2020
for almost half a billion dollar.
For two years we were there until we said,
"We wanna go back to innovation,"
and then we started Upwind.
And a true story about Upwind
and the idea that led
us to build a company.
So back in 2022, when we started Upwind,
we're looking at the market,
and we're looking like what is out there
in terms of, you know, cloud security.
And we saw that there
was a really, you know,
different approach to how you deal
with cloud security back then.
And we said, "We need to
fundamentally change that."
So we're on a mission,
we're building a cloud security platform
with an entirely new
dimension of visibility.
Take you through the whole
journey of securing your code,
configuration, workloads,
application, your data, your APIs,
your AI workloads, but in
a very different approach.
And why is that?
Why does the world need a new CNAPP?
You know, you all probably
know the competitive landscape
of cloud security, the
old players out there,
the most successful one,
the less successful one,
but why the world really needs that?
So if you look at modern architecture,
and especially what happens with AI,
our attackers are leveraging AI,
and now we are building
AI agents and MCPs,
they're just behaving
differently than what we used to.
And what do I mean by that?
So when we look at AI
workload, new architecture,
everything happens at runtime.
Everything happens in real time.
Things are communicating through APIs.
Everything is ephemeral,
keeping minimal state.
Everything is leveraging
data flow, you know,
in real time, in runtime,
and there has to be another
dimension for visibility
that fundamentally
gives you a new approach
to see what happens in your environment.
So you need a visibility
to your API layer.
You need a visibility to
every process execution,
to every network flow in layer three,
layer four, layer seven.
You want a visibility to
how data flows internally
in your environment,
and how it flows from the
internet to your environment
and from your environment outside.
You wanna understand your topology,
you want to understand your
architecture in real time
and see all the changes, why it happens.
And you wanna observe and
detect attacks as they happen.
You can't anymore just
look at your exposure
and attack past and your vulnerabilities
and misconfigurations.
It's important.
But in parallel, you want
to see how things behave
in real time to detect threats,
to respond to them, to
give root cause analysis,
to understand how to
prevent them the next time.
To put the guard rails and
the right policies in place
to secure better the environment.
So Upwind is bringing a fresh new approach
to how we look on
securing your environment.
So we all used to see the
environment from the outside.
We called it an outside in approach.
It was very based on configuration,
on statically scanning the
environment, which is important.
You want to see how you
configure your environment.
You want to see everything
that exists over there.
You do it in an agentless
fashion, it's very quick.
It gives you full inventory visibility,
but you want to include another dimension
that is radically different
than how you approach
cloud security before that.
And that's the inside out
approach we're talking about.
You wanna have the visibility that lives
inside the application,
inside the workload,
that can understand from
the inside how it behaves,
so you can build behavioral
baselines of every application
and workload in your environment,
so you can understand exactly
how it behaves, what it does.
And then you can do two things
very differently than what you used to do.
One, when you have this
dimension of visibility
on your runtime environment,
you can detect threats in real time.
So attackers don't use anymore
non-malicious activities
and leveraging attack paths
that is very easy to detect.
They're using automated AI
tools that are very different
than how we used to detect threats.
Everything now behaves differently.
You want to observe the behavior
and then look at anomalies,
look at deviations from
a regular baseline,
detect threats while they happen,
find indications of compromise,
then connect the dots to create a story
that tells you exactly what
happened, how it happened,
and let you detect things in real time,
let you respond that with
all the context you need.
And the second piece,
now that you have the runtime
context and visibility,
you can really go back to
your posture management,
feed this context to all
your misconfigurations,
compliance issues,
vulnerability management,
and I'll say, is this
critical vulnerability
that CVSS says it's critical?
Is it just critical in the
wild, theoretically critical
for every organization?
Or is it really critical
for my specific workloads
in the way that they behave
in my runtime environment?
And that gives you a
very different approach
to how you prioritize all
your security findings.
Because I can tell you,
no matter what cloud security
platform you use today,
no matter how much it
tells you it can prioritize
your findings in the best way possible,
at the end of the day, you
are suffering from hundreds
or thousands or tens of thousands alerts
that you need to know how to deal with.
And you want to cut through this noise
and deal with the 5, 10,
15 most critical things
when you wake up in the morning.
And how do you do that?
When you really understand
what is critical in your
specific runtime environment,
because now we can say, is the
package that is vulnerable,
or the misconfiguration that is exposing
a critical exposure path,
is it really critical
for my specific workload?
Is the package really
loaded to the memory?
Is the function really being called?
Is the way that I connect
to my different pieces
of my environment, to my sensitive data,
to my exposed internet traffic,
is it really matching to the way
that this vulnerability
can be exploitable?
When you have the runtime
context and the data,
you can actually figure that out,
and cut through this noise and understand
what is really critical in
my specific environment.
So the Upwind Runtime piece
is leveraging all the context
we can get by shifting left,
watching at all your CICD pipeline,
your code changes, your
configuration changes,
your infrastructure's code,
feed that with the dimension
of runtime visibility,
and then take you through
the entire journey
of securing your code,
securing your configuration,
dealing with your own vulnerabilities,
identifying exposed secrets
at rest and in real time,
looking at your data and
how it's being secured,
you know, at rest and in motion.
Baseline every workload
for threat detection.
Do API security on top of it.
Do AI security on top of it.
And that's how you can
really complete the picture
and understand how your
environment behaves,
whether it's really exposed at real time,
what are my most critical
threats that I need
to deal with immediately.
And we have to talk about AI.
Everyone talks about AI these days,
so you know, I have to
spare a minute about that.
When you think about AI security,
everyone talks about
AI security right now.
You can't deal with
securing your AI workloads
with how we traditionally used
to secure our environment.
AI agents, MCPs, they live at runtime,
they're ephemeral, they
keep minimal state,
they communicate with APIs.
Data is flowing in microseconds.
You need to have the runtime visibility
to understand how they behave,
to have a full visibility
to how it actually,
what actually your developers are doing.
Where is my AI workloads
internally and externally?
How data flows to AI services?
What sensitive data go
outside of my environment
to AI services?
How can I detect threats
coming through my MCPs
and AI agents inside my environment?
That all happens at runtime.
So from a postural perspective,
you want the visibility,
you want a graph to query everything,
to understand all the technologies,
all my misconfigurations, all
my critical vulnerabilities.
But from the other side, you
want to understand in real time
when you are being attacked.
So The Upwind Way is all about
give you a full discovery,
put a map of how your environment
looks like in real time.
No more visuals,
no more static snapshots
of your environment.
Real time view on the changes that happen
in your environment, on our data flows,
on our network flows,
on our different pieces
in your architecture are being changed,
we put it on a timeline.
You can watch it like a Netflix movie.
Go back in time, see how
things change, investigate,
and find the real critical
pieces of your environment
and with critical threats.
That's the first thing.
The second piece, now
that we have this data,
identify all your exposures
and reduce your attack surface.
The third piece, fix the
5% that really matters.
Not the thousands of alerts you have,
like the 5 to 10 alerts
that when you wake up
in the morning, your security
engineer, your SOC engineers,
your DevOps people
opening up the dashboard,
opening up the Jira dashboard,
whatever ticketing system you are using,
they're dealing with these
specific critical findings
that would really secure your environment
and make them believe in
your security as well.
And then the fourth piece,
you really want to have this engine
that gives you peace at day and at night,
that you always have the right engine
to detect threats as they happen.
That can block attacks,
that can prevent them from happening,
that can give you the whole story
and the chain of events
on how attackers got
into your environment,
how we got permissions,
how we escalated that,
how we got into your specific data
and network secrets and everything,
and where you can stop it in this journey.
So you know that we can detect it,
you know that we can prevent it.
And the worst case, you know
that you can respond to it.
When you leave at runtime,
you can kill a process.
Like go to the level of the
process that is being executed
inside the container to stop an attack,
to stop a network path,
to stop an API path,
to stop a path to
sensitive data and so on.
You want to have all these
capabilities in real time
to really deal with all
these kind of threats.
So with Upwind, you can
get started in minutes,
you get our agentless cloud scanners
that gives you full visibility
to how your environment
is being behaved, is configured,
is leaving your environment.
And then the other side,
the runtime sensors,
which are the heart of our
platform that feed data
to every piece of our platform
that gives you this visibility.
They are being automatically managed,
automatically being deployed.
They're so easy based on EVPF,
so lightweight that you won't even feel
that they exist over there.
But these are like the heart
and the soul of the platform
that gives you this new
dimension of runtime,
this new possibilities from a visibility
and defend perspective to really secure
your traditional workloads,
but also the new era of AI,
leveraging AI capabilities
to secure it and secure
every new stuff you build
in your environment.
And the platform covers you
with all the different use
cases you can think about
in your cloud security journey.
From all your posture,
from a cloud and data and AI perspective,
all your workload and
infrastructure security,
and of course the runtime
threat protection.
So we are securing every
piece of your cloud stack,
every use case you can
consolidate many different tools
that you used to use
into a single platform
that can really give you
the right visibility,
cut through the noise,
and really secure you
in this modern architecture and cloud era.
And with that I really wanna
welcome you to our booth.
It's in aisle 600.
It's a self shop with a
self bot and cool T-shirts.
So you can see a demo, see how
it looks like in real life,
talk about your specific
need, your architecture,
and how we can help with that.
So thank you very much.
I'll be here for a few
minutes if anyone wants
to have a conversation,
and welcome all of you to our booth.